[Music]
all right so he has the underhook and a
grab okay I'm here like
this when when I'm ready when the energy
tells me to that's when I do this move
so without energy the basics I already
have the elbow tie I'm going to come up
wrap it
around and feet are under me bring his
weight onto my
butt that's the
Dr fit in into don't pull and and
contest here fit inside the space that
you have do you see
yes fit
inside that's the Drone okay let's try
Okay so because I'm going under the
vertical plane you's got to be coming
that way and I got to be on the line of
attack okay so so he's here and I feel
him driving and instead of doing
this right I'm going to go under it here
okay let's try it
the next the collar tie let's say has
the same grab and the color TI okay and
remember I'm going to use this shoulder
to peel that off and not have the two
on this arm is is your relevant okay
okay I'm
here catch the two
them get
weight on the
shoulder weight on the
shoulder okay let's
try so we're right here right b i TR for
that he's going to go up right he's not
going to let me do that especially big
guy like this and then here is I'm going
to rotate around and I have the same arm
position and we'll do the same Dr first
Dr let's bring him off
his boom boom right I go down he goes up
boom there it is bring him off
[Music]
okay over your shoulder
try all right so now you found the
[Music]
same same exact
okay let's
try for